bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8
cultures merci de nous rejoindre une
nouvelle saison culturelle démarre dès
septembre prochain pour nous l'occasion
de parler donc des programmations des
lieux culturels 5 continents et je
reçois ce soir 4 directeurs de salle
alors je vais commencer avec vous Sabine
que c'est un bonsoir donc vous
représentez le prisme à Élancourt à côté
de vous Claude robinski vous représentez
vous la Merise à Trappes en face de vous
Samuel Denis bonsoir vous représentez le
scarabée à la verrière et enfin Yoann
lavabo bonsoir vous représentez donc la
ferme de béliba à Guyancourt Sabine
concert je vais commencer avec vous
alors le prisme cette nouvelle
programmation pour la saison 2013 2014
qui accède donc autour de la danse du
théâtre du jazz ce sont beaucoup
d'artistes internationaux alors dites
nous pourquoi pourquoi ce choix c'est un
choix c'est notamment si je commence par
le jazz c'est évident que il y a
beaucoup d'artistes internationaux
notamment américains qui font du jazz et
on ne sait comme le prisme est une scène
jazz c'est vrai que quand j'ai su qu'il
passait par la France ou par Paris et
bien je me suis précipitée pour attraper
des volants de passage ou Grégory porter
vous avez un public vraiment oui donc et
qui est fidèle en plus c'est et puis qui
peut même venir de loin justement donc
c'est aussi pour ça que c'est bien de
pouvoir faire cet effort là après en
théâtre s'intéressant parce que il y a
des expériences comme
théâtre de superamas ou là c'est un des
acteurs enfin du moins des gens qui
produisent qui sont aussi bien
néerlandais Autrichiens français ou
belge et puis et puis on danse également
puisque on aura un hommage à Jim
Morrison papa au Loris Bero qui est
portugais on a cette jeune chorégraphe
sud-africaine d'Anna massilio qui va et
ça sera mon coup de coeur nous présenter
son Swan Lake sans Lac des cygnes
et juste avant de revenir j'ai juste
précisé que on a également un Canadien
Sylvain Emma et qui a une belle
gestuelle une belle danse danser
aujourd'hui donc Dana massilio une jeune
chorégraphe africaine danseuse africaine
magnifique sculpturale et qui s'attaque
depuis longtemps et c'est ce qu'elle
aime alors elle est passée par le
classique elle est arrivée aux écritures
contemporaines est-ce qu'elle aime c'est
décaler les œuvres donc la langue des
signes est une œuvre évidemment
classique un balai connu pour tout le
monde mais par contre elle elle va y
mettre des accents africains c'est
danseurs sont tous africains non pas de
pointe puisque toute la gestuelle
académique sur le Lac des cygnes et sur
pointe et par contre ils vont avoir un
assez fabuleux déhanché qui va nous
exprimer les plumes du signe qui peut
bouger et autres donc elle a elle a fait
un vrai travail puisse mais on a la
musique de Tchaïkovski qui est pure dans
la totalité et puis par contre ces
danseurs qui nous feront une proposition
mais enthousiasmante extrêmement
dynamique et généreuse écoutez je vous
propose qu'on regarde un extrait donc de
ce lac des signes revisité
alors vous soutenez également un projet
qui est de donner une place plus
importante aux femmes alors c'est un
projet d'ailleurs que vous ambition
commune que vous partagez donc avec
Yoann lavabo vous pour aussi pour la
ferme de bel-eba alors est-ce que vous
arrivez réellement à donner une parité
dans ce milieu artistique oui oui tout à
fait effectivement le prisme et la ferme
de bel-eba sont deux théâtres qui se
sont inscrits dans la saison égalité 1
en Île de France puisqu'il y a eu
d'abord des saisons égalité en
Rhône-Alpes donc c'est la première
saison en Île-de-France que
l'association HF organise et donc l'idée
est effectivement de promouvoir la place
des femmes artistes dans les
programmations où elles sont
extraordinairement sous représentés
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer donc oui la ferme de béléba
fait j'irai un effort particulier à une
attention toute particulière dans ce
domaine et nous présentons cette saison
comme la précédente une programmation
paritaire donc
paritaire réellement paritaire il y a
autant d'hommes hauteur que de femmes
autrices d'hommes metteur en scène que
de femmes mettent aux en scène d'accord
l'égalité pour l'instant ça regroupe 25
théâtres en Île de France des structures
extrêmement disparaître puisque ça va du
Théâtre National de la Colline donc
forcément une très grande structure à
des structures parfois très petites je
pense par exemple à la maison d'Europe
et d'Orient situé à Paris et puis tous
les lieux intermédiaires ça va du CDN au
théâtre de ville il faut quand même dire
qu'il y a beaucoup de théâtres de ville
alors on va pouvoir illustrer
ce moment que l'on consacré aux femmes
en l'occurrence c'est vrai que tous les
mois de mars à Guyancourt a lieu un
événement qui s'appelle le temps des
femmes on va regarder un extrait donc
d'une pièce que vous proposez et qui est
un échange autour de Marilyn Monroe donc
on va regarder
qui appartenait vous
j'appartiens à tous ceux qui veulent de
moi aux hommes aux producteurs au public
vous savez tout le monde m'a pris un
morceau pour le changer Grace maki mes
cheveux
Fred carger mes dents Johnny Hyde mon
nez et mes joues ben lionne mon nom et
j'adorais ça vous n'imaginez pas
ma plus grande jouissance était l'hiver
1954 mon apparition en Corée
à qui appartenait
à la peur
voilà beaucoup de on sent quelque chose
de très très fort qui se dégage de ce
spectacle oui c'est un très bon
spectacle alors c'est assez particulier
assez intimiste et c'est un spectacle
qui donne la parole à Marilyn Monroe
puisqu'en fait les paroles qui sont
prononcées sur scène par Stéphanie Marc
sont les paroles que Marilyn Monroe a
elle-même adressé à son petit canaliste
sous forme de cassettes audio les trois
dernières années de sa vie et vraiment
on est loin on est on est très très loin
des clichés on est très loin de l'image
publique de Marilyn Monroe et elle
révèle une profondeur d'être absolument
exceptionnelle
d'accord alors on revient à votre
programmation je crois que cette année
il y a de la nouveauté avec quatre temps
forts de quoi s'agiter oui on a on a
voulu créer quatre journées quatre
grandes journées ce sont quatre samedi
il y en a un au mois d'octobre au mois
de décembre puis au mois de mars Au mois
de mai et chacune de ces journées
consacrée à une discipline donc la
première au clown la deuxième au compte
la troisième à la poésie et la quatrième
à la marionnette et dans ces journées on
propose à chaque fois cinq ou six
spectacles ça commence le matin ça finit
le soir et l'idée c'est que les
spectateurs grandissent au fil des
heures donc le matin on s'adresse aux
plus jeunes spectateurs parfois à partir
de 6 mois ou un an en ce qui concerne le
compte et la poésie et ça se termine
avec des propositions pour un public
plutôt adulte à 21h
donc en fait l'idée de cette
programmation c'est de créer finalement
un peu un festival c'est ça et de mettre
l'accent sur des disciplines qui sont
pas toujours à suffisamment représentés
peut-être oui c'est aussi histoire de
montrer comment une même discipline peut
toucher vraiment effectivement tous les
arts
publics mais le jeune public c'est
toujours du théâtre du conte de la
marionnette
la ferme de bel-eba répond à cahier des
charges vis-à-vis du jeune public donc
chaque enfance scolarisé dans la ville
de Guyancourt assiste à une
représentation gratuitement souvent à
une deuxième donc effectivement on a une
offre un jeune public très conséquente
c'est un tiers de la de la programmation
alors
cette attention
également à la Meuse attrape alors
Claude robinsky en effet le jeune public
on peut le dire je crois que la
population trappe les enfants en tout
cas ça peut être 30% donc vous avez une
vraie demande comment vous y répondez
alors par les spectacles jeunes publics
comme à la ferme de Bel et Ben
et puis en même temps par une
programmation familiale parce qu'en fait
à Trappes
les les familles sortent ensemble c'est
à dire que les adultes
sortent moins souvent seul ils sortent
forcément avec les enfants familial une
sortie familiale donc la programmation
est vraiment faite pour en priorité bien
sûr pour pour le public familial pour
qu'ils puissent sortir
ensemble et la particularité vous avez
aussi vraiment pris en compte décidé de
prendre en compte
la scénographie du lieu on rappelle à la
Merise et sous forme de cube et c'est
pas toujours adapté à toutes les
disciplines alors comment comment vous y
répondez là aussi à cette cette
configuration
très simplement en faisant appel au
artistes parce qu'en fait cette salle a
été conçue il y a un peu plus de 20 ans
comme une salle dédiée aux musiques
actuelles
sur ce plateau en fait le théâtre passe
assez mal la danse difficilement aussi
par contre ça devient
une salle idéale quand on quand il y a
plus de gradins quand il y a plus rien
et donc on reconstruit à l'intérieur une
structure j'ai donc fait appel à par
exemple du cirque voilà
des artistes circassiens donc il y a pas
mal de cire et puis il y a aussi on peut
parler l'ouverture de saison qui va se
faire avec un spectacle assez original
notamment de la danse verticale et un
orchestre de cuivre comment comment
c'est fait cette combinaison et en fait
là encore c'est en partant de la
scénographie c'est à dire que évidemment
ce lieu doit être signalé de l'extérieur
et
la mère de le signaler bien sûr bon
c'est les calicots mais je peux pas
mettre des pieds
200 mètres de qualité autour de la Meuse
donc on le signale par un acte
artistique il y a une compagnie qui est
spécialisée dans ce domaine c'est
l'accompagner retour à mon qui fait de
la danse verticale qui vraiment c'est
pas de l'acrobatie c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment de la danse c'est très
très harmonieux très très beau et pour
les accompagner j'ai demandé à
l'orchestre manifesto qui est dirigé par
Mélanie
les vitiébault qui est une vraie chef
d'orchestre et qui va diriger vraiment
dans la rue cette section de cuivre et
donc là on a joué sur les oppositions de
forme en fait c'est pas parce qu'on est
dans la rue qu'on va faire du spectacle
de rue non on est dans la rue mais on
fait appel à un orchestre classique donc
on est vraiment dans
un particulier cette année alors autre
particularité vous proposez aussi dans
votre programmation des musiques
traditionnelles pour pourquoi là aussi
ce choix qu'est-ce qui vous amène à
rentrer vers ce type de musique tout
d'abord c'est la population de Trappes
la population de Trappes il y a au moins
plus de 70 nationalités
c'est
nationalités sont souvent des
sont de culture traditionnelle
orale et la musique traditionnelle est
une musique de tradition orale mais
c'est une musique savante oui la musique
se transmet de façon elle se transmet en
fait elle ne s'apprend pas à travers un
solfège et
la musique traditionnelle permet
justement
d'une part de montrer que les savantes
aussi savantes que notre musique
classique c'est aussi pour ça qu'il y a
de la musique classique aussi à la Meuse
et puis c'est une musique qui qui
rencontre qui touche directement les
gens